well the entertainment world is mourning
the passing of american comedy actress
betty white who died on new year's eve
she made her television debut back in
1939.
white remained in the public eye until
her death and had been planning to
celebrate her 100th birthday this month
the grand dame of american television
had the longest career of any woman in
the entertainment industry spanning more
than six decades
betty white's saucy charm gave life to
numerous memorable and quirky characters
she earned two emmy awards for her role
on the mary tyler moore show in the
1970s as the snide lusty sue ann nivens
i'm sorry but this is a very critical
time
well i'm sorry this is a very critical
time for me too
[Laughter]
oh
my poor baby
[Applause]
but she was best known for playing the
dim-witted rosen island in the golden
girls a 1980s sitcom that broke
boundaries by featuring four senior
women living together in miami
you haven't even touched your mr haha
dog
when asked about her decades of success
white chalked up her long career to good
health good fortune and loving her work
i've been working in this
wonderful business for 63 years now
and
i'm so lucky to be as busy as i am
i'll i'll say no when they stop asking
me so if you want me to retire stop
asking me the news of betty white's
death sparked an outpouring of tributes
with fans gathering at a makeshift
memorial over her star on the hollywood
walk of fame
u.s president joe biden tweeted his own
tribute
saying betty white brought a smile to
the lips of generations of americans
she's a cultural icon who will be sorely
missed
the beloved and groundbreaking actress
died just 18 days short of her 100th
birthday
culture editor haleida abara is here to
talk some more about betty white hi
helena um she will be remembered
naturally for the golden girls but her
career is about much more absolutely by
the end of it she had 120 acting credits
and dozens of awards among them seven
emmy awards um in 2014 the guinness book
of records declared her the female
entertainer entertainer with the longest
tv career as well now as we heard she
started in the 1940s back when tv was a
novel new medium and continued right
through to the present day of cable and
streaming a long career
she was born in illinois moved to l.a as
a child during the great depression
she started in radio and had already
become a regular tv personality by the
1940s
as we saw in the report throughout the
1950s she had memorable roles in a
number of tv sitcoms and she established
herself in the u.s in shows like life
with elizabeth the mary tyler moore show
she even had her own show
um the betty white show she was also a
staple on various game shows but it was
of course in the golden girls when she
really became an international star and
became known to new generations right
wikipedia told me that that ran for
seven seasons so it's clearly a success
but why was it considered groundbreaking
well this was the first show where you
had older women as the main protagonist
not just playing supporting characters
not just the mothers not just the
grandmothers
um it's still difficult for older actors
to get you know starring good roles back
then it was really unheard of let alone
to to achieve international stardom
doing so we saw white and her co-stars
navigating things um you often see on tv
only young people doing you know like
dating and
um job hunting and the show was also
credited with a number of firsts it was
kind of the first time we saw a group of
adults living together rather than the
nuclear family it was proof that you
could still be single and not and have
and still have friendship and still have
love it blazed the trail for iconic
shows that followed like friends and
like sex and the city
um it also showed you that it's okay for
women to be sexually voracious not just
women but older women and single older
single women this was before sex and the
city's samantha jones yeah you had rue
mcclanahan's blanche who spent most of
her time trying to seduce these
supporting male characters and most
impactful it tried to lift the stigma on
hiv and aids there's an episode where
betty white's character
rose actually not naive very naive not
promiscuous she thinks she's contracted
hiv and one of her lines are it's not a
bad person's disease now this was in the
mid 1980s when people were blamed for
their having a's blamed people said it
was their own fault it's still regarded
as an example of brilliant comedy acting
and brilliant comedy writing today yep
the list goes on and on what a long list
it is for betty white helena thanks so
much
you